le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov rencontre pour
quelques heures son homologue américain
anthony blinken à genève ils doivent
discuter des garanties que moscou
demande à l'occident sur fond de
tensions croissantes sur l'ukraine il
s'agit d'une nouvelle tentative de
dialogue mais les espoirs sont minces
chacun campe sur ses positions
l'ukraine accuse le kremlin de préparer
des soldats à sa frontière pour
dissuader kiev de se rapprocher de
l'otan en écoute sergueï lavrov puis
anthony blinken
nous ne nous attendons pas non plus à
une avancée lors de ces négociations
ce que nous attendons ce sont des
réponses concrètes à nos propositions
concrètes
c'est un moment critique
vous avez raison nous ne nous attendons
pas à résoudre nos différends ici
aujourd'hui
mais j'espère et j'attends que nous
puissions essayer de voir si la voie de
la diplomatie du dialogue reste ouverte
nous sommes déterminés à prendre cette
voie et à résoudre pacifiquement nos
différents j'espère que nous pourrons
essayer cela dès aujourd'hui et voir où
cela va nous mener
on retrouve elena volochine notre
correspondante à moscou dès le début de
la rencontre le ton reste ferme on
montre ses muscles de part et d'autre
oui on n'a pas entendu mais anthony
blinken a aussi ouvertement parlé
d'agression russe possible contre
l'ukraine sergueï lavrov quant à lui a
dit effectivement ne pas attendre de
résultats mais des réponses concrètes
alors réponse à quoi ils la russie veut
obtenir des réponses écrites à deux
projets d'accord transmis mi décembre
aux états unis et à l'otan en l'espèce
il s'agit en quelque sorte de pacte de
non-agression ou la russie propose à
washington et à l'alliance atlantique de
s'engager à ne pas s'élargir à ne pas
élargir l'otan aux pays de l'ex bloc
soviétique et notamment à l'ukraine
également la russie veut obtenir des
garanties comme quoi ni les états unis
ni l'otan ne mèneront de manoeuvres
militaires sur le territoire de ces pays
de l'ex bloc soviétique alors
la semaine dernière des discussions à ce
sujet entre la russie et les etats-unis
et la russie et l'otan ont échoué à
aboutir à un accord c'est pour cela
notamment aujourd'hui que se rencontrent
sergueï lavrov et anthony blinken c'est
très important pour la partie russe elle
le martèle elle veut obtenir de
washington une réponse écrite à ses
projets à ces deux documents mais le
porte parole de vladimir poutine dmitri
peskov aujourd'hui a dit qu' on ne
s'attendait pas finalement à ce qu
anthony blinken bienne à genève avec de
telles réponses écrites il s'agit
aujourd'hui de discuter de mettre ses
positions sur la table de clarifier les
positions de chaque partie pour voir
comment faire avancer les discussions et
qu'elles pourraient être les termes d'un
compromis possible
alors ça c'est absolument impossible de
le dire à ce stade ni pour nous ni pour
d'ailleurs sans doute sergueï lavrov et
anthony blinken encore une fois le but
de cette rencontre n'est pas là ce n'est
pas aujourd'hui à genève d'obtenir un
compromis ou un accord c'est plutôt de
comprendre les positions de chacun ce
qu'on sait de cette rencontre c'est
qu'elle se déroule à l'initiative de la
partie américaine sergueï lavrov l'a dit
c'est anthony blinken qui a exprimé
cette volonté de le rencontrer lors de
leurs échanges téléphoniques il n'y aura
pas non plus d'ailleurs de conférence de
presse conjointe à l'issue et puis on
l'a entendu ce ton très ferme au départ
donc pas de compromis en vue pour
l'heure alors même que la menace
militaire et la menace d'une guerre
ouverte en ukraine fait trembler tout le
monde mais à l'heure actuelle en tout
cas il s'agit au moins de cette volonté
de discuter de voir
quelles pourraient être les termes de
ces discussions sinon d'un compromis et
donc il faut attendre l'issue de ses
discussions pour pouvoir interview merci
beaucoup et léna vologe